en este vídeo vamos a hacer algo así
como un juego tenemos tres conjuntos de
datos y quisiera saber si estos datos
corresponden a una relación lineal a una
cuadrática cuadrática oa una función
exponencial si una función exponencial a
manera de recordatorio una función
lineal tiene la forma de igual a mx más
ve una cuadrática es igual a x cuadrada
más bx más c y un exponencial es igual a
igualdad a una constante digámosle a a x
r a la x bien la manera de distinguir
entre estas y probablemente te es más
intuitiva una lineal o tal vez la
exponencial la cuadrática no es tan
intuitiva pero la técnica que voy a
utilizar y que demostraré en el próximo
vídeo nos dará la idea del caso general
y por qué funciona distinguimos las
funciones
porque cambios constantes en x producen
cambios constantes en que se incrementó
x en 1 se incrementará en una cantidad
fija así que utilizando esto como
nuestra primer guía observemos cuál de
estas representa una función lineal
veamos en todos estos ejemplos lo
importante es primero observar la
variación de x que vaya de uno en uno
eso es fundamental porque si éste no
fuera el caso tendríamos que ajustar las
cosas de otra manera
ahora observemos nuestros datos en ye y
vemos que entre el primer dato y el
segundo hay una diferencia de 60 entre
el segundo y el tercero es de 90 y en el
tercero hay una variación de 135 y
resultó no ser lineal cuando x varía en
1 aquí tenemos un cambio de 60 y luego
un cambio de 90 y otro de 135 y
claramente esta no es una función lineal
veamos la siguiente veamos el cambio de
los valores de iu en el primer caso es
de 2 en él
siguientes de cero y otra vez no es
lineal ya que para cambios iguales de x
ya no crece ni decrece de una manera
constante otra vez está no es lineal
veamos la última primero verificamos que
x efectivamente se incrementa en 1 luego
vemos los cambios en g
del primero al segundo decrece en 3 del
segundo al tercero también te crecen
tres del tercero al cuarto decrece en
tres del cuarto al quinto decrece en
tres y decrece en tres así que cada vez
que x se incrementa en 1 se reduce su
valor en 3 así que tenemos una pendiente
constante nuestro cambio en entre
nuestro cambio en x es igual a que
cuando x se reduce en 1 y reduce en 3 y
esta es la definición de pendiente la m
de la ecuación los cambios son
constantes por lo que esta es lineal
está que está aquí es lineal el caso de
la cuadrática
es muy interesante y se presta para
enseñarte este truco y que veas que
funciona lo que hay que observar aquí es
que los cambios en y no serán constantes
no serán constantes como en el caso de
la función lineal sino que el cambio del
cambio ese es el que será constante lo
voy a escribir porque puede que en este
momento no te haga mucho sentido
el cambio
en el cambio
y
es constante esto es a lo que me refiero
veamos este primer caso de 120 a 180
tenemos un incremento de 60 de 180 a 270
tenemos uno de 90 de 270 a 405 tenemos
un incremento de 135 pero cuando hable
del cambio en el cambio de iu me refería
a que estos son los cambios en g pero
cuáles son los cambios de los cambios
así que en este caso es de 30 o lo
puedes ver como la diferencia de la
diferencia y ahora tenemos de 90 a 135 o
sea que el cambio es de 45 así vemos que
el cambio del cambio o la diferencia de
las diferencias pasamos de 60 al 90 que
es un incremento de 30 y después pasamos
de 90 a 135 que es un incremento de 45 y
este cambio no fue constante lo que nos
dice que esta no es una función
cuadrática
ahora observemos está y vemos por el
cambio en jake que tampoco corresponde a
una lineal aquí incrementa en dos aquí
hay un cero aquí incremente al menos dos
la siguiente menos cuatro luego en menos
seis los cambios en definitivamente no
son constantes pero ahora veamos cuál es
el cambio del cambio de donde hubo un
incremento de 2 al incremento de 0
tenemos un cambio de menos 2 el cambio
del cambio o la diferencia de las
diferencias luego del incremento de 0 al
de menos 2 volvemos a tener un cambio de
menos 2 ahora del -2 al menos 4 volvemos
a tener un cambio de menos 2 y esto
empieza a tener cara de ser cuadrática
después tenemos del -4 al menos 6 y otra
vez tenemos un cambio de menos 2 así que
estos datos que tenemos aquí satisfacen
muy bien nuestro requerimiento de
cuadrática por ahora sólo hemos dado el
truco de cómo identificarlo en el
próximo vídeo te mostraré porque esto
funciona y haremos
ejemplos así esto que tenemos aquí
corresponde a una cuadrática así que
dirás bueno en los ejemplos tenemos una
línea el otro cuadrática otro
exponencial entonces esto deberá ser
exponencial y probablemente tienes la
razón pero ahora te voy a decir qué
hacer para saber si es exponencial así
que cuando x se incrementa en 1 en una
relación exponencial siempre tendrás un
factor que multiplica de manera
constante esto es al revisar término por
término guardarán una proporción entre
ellos en una relación exponencial no
observaremos las diferencias entre los
términos en lo que vamos a observar es
la proporción que hay entre términos
consecutivos y verificar que es la misma
entonces cuando x se incrementó en uno
de varios de 120 a 180 así que el
incremento es 18 entre 12 que es 1.5
revisando los otros términos y déjame
primero borrar esto que está aquí
así que ir de este término al otro es
1.5 veces e ir de 180 a 270 parece
también 1.5 veces 90 es la mitad de 180
que si lo sumo llego al 270 1.5 veces de
270 a 405 son 135 que es en lo que
estamos incrementando y es otra vez 1.5
veces y cada uno de los términos es el
anterior 1.5 veces lo que nos dice que
esto que está aquí es 1.5 pero el punto
que aquí nos interesa más bien es la
identificación así que al menos con los
datos que tenemos aquí esto es
exponencial si una función exponencial
en fin espero que esto haya sido
divertido